it is a big honor for me to address you
at this crucial moment in history
and I salute the courage with which you
are meeting today the way you have
continued to meet in spite of the
barbaric Onslaught on your freedoms
day after day missiles and bombs
continue to Reign on the innocent people
of Ukraine and in the South and the east
of your wonderful country Putin
continues with his grotesque and illegal
campaign to take and hold Ukrainian soil
and his soldiers no longer have the
excuse of not knowing what they are
doing
they are committing war crimes
and their atrocities emerge wherever
they are forced to retreat as we've seen
at Buca at airpin at hostel and many
other places
and we in the UK will do whatever we can
to hold them to account for these war
crimes
and in this moment of uncertainty of
continuing fear and doubt about the
future
I have one message for you today
Ukraine will win
and I'll tell you why I believe you will
succeed
dear members of the Rada when they came
to me last year and they said that there
was no overwhelming evidence that Putin
was planning an invasion and we could
see his Battalion tactical groups well
over a hundred of them Gathering On the
Border I also I remember a sense of of
Horror but also of puzzlement
because I've been to give on previous
visits and I'd actually I think I'd met
some of you and I'd stood in the maidan
and I'd seen the tributes to those who
had given their lives to protect Ukraine
against Russian aggression
and I've wandered the lovely streets of
your capital
and I've seen enough
about Ukrainian freedom to know that the
Kremlin was making a fundamental
miscalculation
a terrible mistake and I told everybody
I knew
anybody who would listen that Ukraine
would fight and Ukraine would be right
and yet there were some who believed the
Kremlin propaganda that Russian armor
would be like an irresistible Force
going like a knife through butter and
Kiev would fall in days do you remember
they said that and people rang Vladimir
and they offered him safe passage out of
the country and he said no thanks and
they said that this
rather of yours would have to be
reformed outside Ukraine maybe even in
in Poland or or in London perhaps and I
refused to believe it
and today you have proved them
completely wrong every one of those
military experts who said that Ukraine
would fall
and your Farmers your Farmers kidnapped
Russian tanks with their tractors
your pensioners stood up in the road and
told Russian soldiers to hop it
as we say well they may use they may
have used more colorful language than
that
and even in the parts of Ukraine
that were temporarily captured
your populations your indomitable
populations turned out to protest day
after day
and though your soldiers were always
outnumbered three to one it is now they
fought with the courage and the energy
of lions
and you've beaten them back from Kiev
you have exploded the myth of Putin's
invincibility
and you've written one of the most
glorious chapters in military history
and in the life of your country
the so-called irresistible force of
Putin's war machine has broken on the
immovable object
of Ukrainian patriotism and love of
country
this is Ukraine's finest hour
that will be remembered and recounted
for generations to come your children
and your grandchildren will say that
ukrainians taught the world that the
brute force of an aggressor counts for
nothing against the moral force of a
people determined to be free
they will say that ukrainians proved by
their tenacity and sacrifice that guns
and tanks cannot suppress a nation
fighting for its independence
and that is why I believe and I know
that Ukraine will win
you've proved the old saying
it's not
it's not the size of the dog in the
fight
it's the size of the fight in the dog
and
which is an Old English saying I don't
know whether how well that translates
into Ukrainian
but you get what I'm trying to say
and as you turn the Russian army back
from the gates of Kiev you not only
accomplished one of the greatest Feats
of arms of the 20th century 21st century
you achieve something deeper and perhaps
equally significant
you exposed the historic folly
that Putin has made
when a leader Rules by fear and when he
rigs his elections and when he jails his
critics and he refuses to have a free
media and he listens just to sycophants
and when there's no limits on his power
that is when he makes catastrophic
mistakes
and it's precisely because we understand
the this Danger
in Britain and in Ukraine and because
precisely because we are democracies
and that we have a uh free media the
rule of law free elections robust
parliaments such as your own we know
that these are the best protections
against
The Perils of arbitrary power
and when an autocrat deliberately
destroys those institutions he might
look as though he's strong
and some people might even believe it
but he's sowing the seeds of catastrophe
for himself and for his country
because there will be nothing to prevent
him committing another terrible mistake
Putin's mistake
was to invade Ukraine and the carcasses
of Russian armor littering your fields
and streets are monuments not only to
his folly but to the dangers of
autocracy itself
and what he has done is an advertisement
for democracy
on a day when Putin thought he would be
in charge of Kiev I had the honor of
being able to visit your your wonderful
City and I saw the the Defiance of the
people of Ukraine and I know so much
about the terrible price that ukrainians
have paid and are paying for your
heroism
today at least one Ukrainian in every
four has been driven from their homes
two-thirds of all Ukrainian children are
now refugees whether inside the country
or elsewhere
so no outsider
like me can speak lightly
about how this conflict could be settled
if only Ukraine
would relinquish this or that
piece of territory or we find some
compromise
for Vladimir Putin
and we know what happens
to the people who are left behind
in the clutches of this Invader and
we who are your friends must be humble
about what happened in in 2014.
because Ukraine was invaded before for
the first time and Crimea was taken
forth from Ukraine and the war in the
donbass began
and the truth is that we were too slow
to grasp what was really happening and
we collectively failed to impose the
sanctions then that we should have put
on Vladimir Putin and we cannot make the
same mistake again
and it's precisely because of your Valor
your courage your sacrifice
that ukrainians now control your own
destiny and you are the masters of your
fate and no one
can or should impose anything on
ukrainians
and all I will say is that we in the UK
will be guided by you and we are proud
to be your friends and I'm proud that
our ambassador
Melinda Simmons
is back in Kiev I know you know Melinda
to reopen our Embassy
and in January of course as as you were
kind enough to say Mr chairman just
before Putin launched his onslaught
we sent you plane loads of anti-tank
missiles uh the end Labs which I think
have now become popular
in Kiev and elsewhere and we have
intensified that vital effort
working with dozens of countries helping
to coordinate an Ever bigger supply line
and we're sending many uh thousands of
weapons of every kind including tanks
now and armored vehicles
in the coming weeks we in the UK will be
sending you Brimstone anti-ship missiles
and Stormer anti-aircraft systems and
we're providing armored vehicles to
evacuate civilians from areas under
attack and protect officials as of what
Vladimir mentioned to me in our most
recent call Protect officials while they
maintain critical infrastructure
I can announce today from the UK
government a new package of support
totaling 300 million pounds including
Radars to pinpoint the artillery
bombarding your cities
heavy lift drones to supply your forces
and thousands of night vision devices
we will carry on supplying Ukraine
alongside your other friends with
weapons with funding and humanitarian
aid until we have achieved our long-term
goal
which must be so to fortify Ukraine
that no one will ever dare attack you
again
here in the UK
in my country
you will see Ukrainian flags flying
everywhere from church spiers and in
shop Windows you see Ukrainian ribbons
on the lapels of people up and down the
country and there are many reasons why
your country has evoked such astonishing
sympathy in the British people
it's a conflict that has no moral
ambiguities or gray areas
this is about the right of ukrainians to
protect themselves against Putin's
violent and murderous aggression it's
about Ukraine's right to Independence
and National self-determination against
Putin's deranged imperialist revanchism
it's about Ukrainian democracy against
Putin's tyranny it's about Freedom
versus oppression it's about right
versus wrong it's about good versus evil
and that is why
Ukraine must win
and when we look at the heroism of the
Ukrainian people
and The Bravery of your leader
Vladimir zielinski we know that Ukraine
will win
and we in the UK will do everything we
can to restore a free Sovereign and
independent Ukraine thank you all very
much for listening to me today and Slava
Ukraine